So the space pod is over there
but I'm gonna be an idiot and go over here
No one told me there was a house
Squeeeaaakkkk
Switch to the candle
Yeah. Much bet-
Oh nooo
Ah-ha!
Oh, nothing?
Good-
Well how was I supposed to know-
This is probably not a good thing
Depending on the length of each part...
Hi!
Try to reach the valley
I haven't seen a single monster yet but I-
What the hell was that?!
Okay
Goddammit no!
Holy...Crap!
The keys!
I got the keys!
I just gotta get the F out of here now!
Oh god!
Andddd....It's quiet
What the hell are you!?
Shut up!
I don't need it
What else-
Oh god!
Stop it!
Give me two seconds!
Shut up for two seconds
God dammit!
Nurse Yamimash
AHHHH!Fuck you!
Alright...
What was wrong with you?!
No thank you!
Don't do that to me...
Do you like my pretty face...?
No!(Yes!)
Oh, there we go!
That was a hefty-
WOAH!
WOAH!!!
What the hell are those things?
Spider douches?
Turn it off!
Mother-
What the hell?!
Okay...
Aww god dammit.
What are these..?
Ooookkaaayyyyy.
Okay!
OKAY!
Oh Okay!
Oh there's something behind me!
Something behind me!
What is that?
What happened?
Oh. It's so wrong
It's a red chair.
OHHHHH
It's a CHAIRRR!
I'm gonna go to it!
Uh-Oh
What?
Mark?
The door closed.
Mark!
The door's locked!
UH
Uh
Mark?!
MARK?!
UHH
WOAH
WHAT THE HECK IS THAT?!
GET OFF OF ME!
I can't open the door!
Hello?
What did you do?
I have to hide.
I don't know why, but I have to hide now.
I was already on my way to hide
Under the bed
But I'm gonna do it anyway
Not because you told me to-
OHHH!
Goodness!
OH GOODNESS!
It is inside.
'It is inside'?
NO JOKE!
Don't look up!
Woah!
A-Woah!
Woah. oh-
Oh
OH
I'm suck in a wall!
Mark!
Help!
Help me!
WOAH WHAT THE FUCK
GET OFF OF ME
JESUS!
OH GOD!
hide Hide HIDE HIDE
Are you afraid?
YES!
Thanks for watching my random horror reaction compilation.
If you enjoyed this video, and you want to see more like it,
then please click that subscribe button.
If you wanna help the channel grow, there is no better way than
sharing this video around with your friends and family
Thank you so much for helping out the channel
And thank you for watching.
And as always, I will see you, in the next video!
Bye -bye!